so you've just come from an NHS rally
and ahead of its 70th birthday what
would you main message 70th birthday NHS
absolutely brilliant and I think we
should thank all those that founded it
and the inspiration that came from
working-class communities in South Wales
and other places our message was also
that health is about mental health it is
about social care it is about stress it
is about environmental and public health
and that I want to see the NHS properly
funded
once he announced the privatization give
me an address there were people there
from Lancashire who are on strike at the
moment trying to prevent their jobs
being essentially outsourced to an
internal private company which wouldn't
then pay the national conditions and the
need to ensure that social care and
mental health or property resourced
mental health is the biggest killer of
young men in this country where they
take their own lives and commit suicide
and there was a mental health crisis
that we've all got to face up to so are
you saying that austerity could cost
like this effectively austerity does
cost lives no question about that and
the health inequalities in Britain and
massive women take Scotland for example
to quote in my speech the richest and
best off and healthiest in Scotland live
26 years longer than the poorest and
those in worst health well that cannot
be acceptable you drive across Glasgow
just the life expectancy goes like that
across the city you could say that in
almost any other city in Britain and I
do think we have to address those and
also the issues of environmental health
snow air quality was tackled in the
1950s with the Clean Air Act which was
about smoke great that was gone
but we have far worse substances in the
air now and the air quality in urban
areas and the effect on children's
health is massive children being born
and growing up with limited lung
capacity so my message is fund the NHS
properly fund social care properly and
fun
and fundamentals well let's talk about
the specifics of funding and Theresa
Mays given the NHS a 20 billion pound
birthday present three point four
percent on average over five years what
exactly are you promising what we said
in the election was we'd put far more
money in straight away nothing nothing
that she has promised actually means any
money this year there's no money for
mental health there's no money for
social care and it's only 0.1 percent
above what the IFS says is necessary to
stand still so my understanding is
you're promising five percent more in
the first year but over five years
that's actually less than the
conservative part is you're talking
about the first year they're talking
about five years something we said we
put in five percent the first year tube
deep the deal with the immediate crisis
particularly in hospital waiting lists
and in Social Care ones after that we
would continue increasing at the
necessary rate and it would be higher
than that and do you know what that is
well it depends obviously what the
requirements are but we would increase
what is necessary for the funding of the
NHS but we put that money in for the
first year straightaway as a crisis now
because it resumes promise doesn't
actually make any difference whatsoever
now this winter this financial year but
over five years
currently she's promising more than you
what she's promising over five years is
0.1 percent above standstill budget we
would offer two percent so you guarantee
you'd put more money into in it just in
the concept we would put the money in
that's necessary for it but we would
also deal with the other issues which do
actually impact on our hospitals in that
particular social care and the GP crisis
where there are many older GPS retiring
we're not having enough young GPS coming
on and not enough GPS are coming to work
in this country
so we're specifically then would you put
the money then because this is always a
criticism of funding their neck chest
and isn't it that you just pouring money
into you know a leaky bucket if you like
so where would you direct the money well
I think you've direct the money into the
crisis of the hospitals at the moment
many of which are in deficit quite
serious deficit and therefore having
real problems managing secondly look at
the
use of training and and in the NHS for
nurses and for doctors particularly but
also crucially the issue of social care
because social care is a million people
in need of social care can't get it and
the mental health crisis has a knock-on
effect in many other areas of life and
so those areas need to be properly
funded as well and that also means
funding local government properly I'm
also keen to talk to you about another
big challenge facing politicians of the
minute bricks it feels like we can't do
an interview of course without touching
on and bricks it and in your opinion is
the problem with bricks itself all the
way the government is handling brexit I
think it's the way the government's
handled it because they've never really
been very clear what kind of
relationship they want with Europe I
mean every time Philip Hammond says he
wants X trade arrangement with Europe
Boris Johnson says he wants a trade
agreement with Argentina with Australia
with Peru or somebody else somewhere
else or you got Liam Fox saying well we
can fix all these trade deals in a few
months it doesn't matter they're very
easy to negotiate well eh they're not
and be half of all of our trade is with
Europe and when we've had warnings from
very big employers in this country BMW
Airbus and many others who are very
concerned because if they can't get
their goods in and out and there was a
supply chain that crosses the channel
all the time and if they have to pay
tariffs on those then clearly they're
not going to stay there is an issue that
there has to be a focus by the
government on getting an agreement with
the EU you get the feeling that every
time somebody in the government thinks
what we really should get an agreement
we get cabinet ministers going off in a
tangent and also the white paper on the
objectives or goodness the referendum
was two years ago and the white paper is
only going to come out after apparently
a weekend party at Chequers for the
cabinet so in principle then it's not
brexit you have an issue with it's
through handling a bit is that is that
right I wanted reform and remain that
was not the decision of the British
people there was a referendum result I
wants to have a
effective relationship with Europe which
gives us the trade opportunities but
also does not set us up as a sort of
deregulated economy on the shores of
Europe which is what some Tories want so
if it's done correctly do you think the
brakes that could actually bring
opportunities if it's done correctly we
will have a good relationship with
Europe we will be able to give to
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland many
of the powers that have been of regional
government that were taken to them are
taken away to Brussels and we can ensure
that we have that good relationship but
I'm also concerned that this government
is unclear on Environmental Protection's
unclear on fish agreements unclear on
agriculture and very unclear on
long-term what it does in human rights
and rights across Europe is there a case
for extending the transition do you
think I'm speaking to great Clark for
example this week he said that perhaps
there is we proposed a transition period
in the first place that was a Labour
proposal and that obviously has to be a
transition at the moment it's it's not
set in stone but it's is talked around
but two years I would you know I've got
a feeling it might go beyond that and
would you be happy with that yes because
I do I do think the priority has to be
our investment in different parts of
Britain to ensure we do get fair
economic growth across the whole of the
UK but it also has to be protecting jobs
of those industries that rely on trade
with Europe particularly in the Midlands
and Northeast it's interesting a
speaking to you because you're obviously
keen to say that the issues you have
with the way the government is handling
brexit very different how you would do
it but people in your party members feel
that the issue is with brexit itself
that it should be stopped some people
certainly do and momentum members for
example thousands of them signing this
petition calling for a second referendum
can you rule out a second referendum
leadership that we don't see a second
referendum as on our agenda what we've
said is we want Parliament to have the
right to a final say and how
for a amendable motion on it so we can
actually go through what the deal is the
vote two weeks ago was not to accept
that particular idea but it will come
back to Parliament and we will keep on
with that and we will if we're not happy
with the final negotiations we will vote
against them I'm still a little bit
unclear you're the straight talking
amount of politics if you like are you
ruling out a second referendum look
we've not proposed it we've not support
it and we're not proposing it now so
you're willing it out we're not
supporting a second referendum okay I
think that's probably as close as then
I'm gonna get to that on in that case
and now another big issue of course on
grexit is immigration it's something
that kind of feels that it kind of
splits and labor voters on as well and
you know people outside London for
example lots of working-class voters
being very strongly about immigration
very different opinion to some of you
were more younger metropolitan
supporters so I'm interested to get to
you know the gist of where you are on
immigration do you think that
immigration is too high but it's going
down all the time so I'm very surprised
you even asked the question it's gone
down a great deal over the past I'm
asking the question because for many
people who I've spoken to outside London
they say that that's why they voted to
leave the EU yeah I would ask you to
also recognize that with those that have
come to this country to work here we've
kept our services going particularly
health and social care services where I
think there is a problem is the way in
which employers have brought in groups
of workers deliberately to undercut
people working in this country in
construction but in other industries as
well and my argument with many of the
governments of Central Europe was they
should support protection of rights and
pay levels right across Europe and now
I'm interested in asking you about some
social issues as well and one thing
that's been in the news a lot recently
is the decriminalization of cannabis for
medical reasons you've said that that's
something that you and support so I'm
interested to know is do you feel that
there's an argument that cannabis should
be decriminalized across the board I
think at this stage we should say
medical use of cannabis is good and
cannabis oil used is clearly beneficial
to people and that should be
decriminalized and made readily
available as quickly as possible how
about more widely do you feel that the
recreational use of cannabis should be
decriminalized well I think we have to
look at the health concerns of any drug
that people take no drug is without
consequences when people take it and
personally I don't take any drugs at all
and I think we should just think about
it quite carefully but let's go with
what's proposed now which is the
availability of cannabis for medicinal
purposes and back in 2000 you signed a
motion calling for their possession of
cannabis to be decriminalized if you
change your mind no I think
criminalizing people for possession of
small amounts of cannabis is not
particularly a good idea and does lead
to great difficulties particularly for
younger people in communities like mine
and so I do think the debate is moving
on how about the sex industry is there
an argument that there should be a
decriminalization there I don't think
people that are mainly women that are
working in the sex industry should be
criminalized working in it I think those
that are benefiting from it they are the
ones that we should go after listen so I
do look at what's being done in in
Sweden and in other places on this say
there but I do think there are women who
are being criminalized and because
they've been into prostitution and
grotesquely exploited they're not
criminals they're victims how about
people who buy sex because if you
mentioning the Nordic model that's
slightly different from the UK isn't it
because if you buy sex let's call one of
the Nordic model essentially moves the
blame of the responsibility onto those
promoting the sex industry rather than
those that are working in it and I think
that's a direction that we should think
about going mm-hmm because part of the
reason I'm interval with one of the
reasons I was quite interested in asking
your opinion on this is because there's
reports back in 2016
that you told students at Goldsmiths
University that I'm in favor of
decriminalizing this
industry so you're only saying the women
not the men is that right what I meant
and said was that the women who work in
the industry should not be criminalized
for doing so and then I can't of course
have any interview minute without asking
about the World Cup
lots of our viewers will be very
interested in the minute if you manage
to catch any games yes yes quite a lot
of them actually I I joyfully I enjoy
watching football
both my favourite club Arsenal but also
I enjoy watching young people's football
in my own area my family are very
involved in football and watching
youngsters joined football clubs get
involved in games building that sense of
team spirit an understanding they've got
to rely on each other to achieve
something and understanding the highs
and lows and disappointments I think it
is best is absolutely brilliant and yeah
the World Cup is it's a great time for
us all and in I'm gonna bring back
another early day motion that you signed
on the World Cup this is this one was
from the Euro 96 perhaps the last time
when England did you know quite well in
a kind of international football
well that was we have the great and best
song perhaps it's coming home but
unfortunately it didn't so the motion
that you signed said that you'd applaud
the jingoism and nationalism in the
tabloid press which does nothing to
maintain the true spirit of sport but
it's reminiscent of Hitler's use of
sport to enhance his evil regime so some
pretty strong words that about some of
the coverage of Euro 96 do you think
some of the coverage has gone a bit far
this time I think it tends to get a bit
overboard sometimes I mean it is a game
it is football in his sport and be
passionate about it but remember that
there's a lot of teams that are not
there that would love to be there and a
lot of people love the World Cup all
over the world for that now I think we
should do our best support our team
let's hope they go as far as they
possibly can but above all enjoy the
football I mean I remember I'm old
enough to remember the World Cup 1966
and also to remember those
magnificent Brazilian teams that won
successive World Cups I mean you
couldn't just be anything but mesmerised
by the skill and the intricate passing
and all this and it was like poetry so I
thought his poetry read Albert Camus on
football he's your man I'll have to look
it up look it up he's very good so
perhaps we get a psychology of it but
the psychology of sport and people and
politics and culture is something that I
find quite interesting I don't know if
you've ever had a chance to read CLR
James book beyond a boundary
it's about cricket in the Caribbean
people in the Caribbean playing cricket
in a colonial atmosphere and beat in the
colonial master great book
thank you very much your time I
appreciate it thank you